Greta
thunberg is she's taking a break from
protesting in favor of Gaia and the sun
gods and all the rest of the weather
religion and she is standing with Gaza
and Palestine uh Greta thunberg just
posted a tweet says week 270 today we
strike in solidarity with Palestine and
Gaza 270
weeks at that point I think you just
lose your job but she never had a job so
she's just striking striking is her job
and usually she strikes for the benefit
of the environmental left which uh
profits and grows in power by uh
consolidating the socially and
politically acceptable energy use uh but
today she's decided she's going to
strike for Gaza this is true of the
broader left it's not just the White
House it's not just the professional
activist the sort of marionette of the
liberal regime Greta thunberg it is also
uh Justin Trudeau the leader of
America's evil Top Hat Canada who just
tweets out quote as members of the
Palestinian Arab and black Muslim
communities gathered for prayer
yesterday I wanted them to know this we
know you're worried and hurting we are
here for you we will not stop advocating
for civilians to be protected and for
international law to be upheld I know a
lot of people are confused about which
side to be on here because lot of people
say we don't really have a dog in this
fight the holy land is very far away
this is a conflict that's gone on in
it's present form for well over 100
years and it's a conflict that has gone
on broadly for uh Millennia and so we
we don't really pick a side here uh but
this the side is going to pick you I
guess is how I would say it if you look
around and look at the people who are
supporting Palestine Hamas versus the
people who are supporting the state of
Israel broadly speaking you are going to
see the most prominent leftists who are
wrong about the most things in the most
egregious ways they are generally going
to be on the side of
Palestine and the people with whom you
generally tend to agree are who who are
right about generally the right number
of things they are broadly going to be
supportive of the Israeli government
it's just the I'm not saying that it's a
perfect one to one I'm not saying that
all the interests are totally aligned
but that's what happens Rashid Talib AOC
Ilan
Omar Justin Trudeau Justin Castro Greta
thunberg Joe B all the rest of them they
are pretty vocally on the side of the
Palestinians and if the libs if the
people who are most wrong about
everything are uniformly on the pal on
the side of the Palestinians then
probably that's not the right side to
totally be on right politics is a team
Sport and I know people don't like that
and it makes people uncomfortable and we
all bemoan tribalism that's another one
of these words that cropped up in the
last six seven years that is largely
meaningless but it's it's just a word
that's going around like a meme but
politics is tribal and here we're
talking about one of the most ancient
tribes in the world and a multiple
ancient tribes actually uh fighting over
this and
so it seems ill advised to put yourself
on the side of of uh Greta thunberg and
Trudeau and the the squad in favor of
Palestine Liberation because the
argument for Palestine Liberation is the
anti-colonial argument which is
ultimately just an anti-european anti-
dirty rotten white man argument uh to to
destroy uh anything resembling Western
Civilization that's that's what it's
about someone put it in a py way which
was uh a lot of the left doesn't hate
Israel because they're Jews they hate
Israel because they're white and because
uh the state of Israel uh appears to
have a lot of resemblances to any other
British colonial project much like the
United States and the arguments that are
being wielded right now against the
state of Israel will and in fact are
currently being wielded against the us
as well right now go to goodranchers.com
every Halloween parents are warned about
the potential dangers in their kids
candy but what we don't talk about are
the potential dangers you encounter
every day
in the meat aisle of your grocery store
lab grown meat is growing more popular
and it's not unusual for foreign meat to
be labeled as a product of the United
States and the scary truth is that we
don't really know what's in our meat
unless you like me eat good ranchers
last night I had such a Juicy and
Delicious chicken cutlet well I had
multiple chicken cutlets from good
ranchers I usually just focus on the
beef cuz you know I only eat good
ranchers what three times a week four
times a week if I'm lucky and so I want
to I want to f focus it on the beef and
the steak and the burgers best burger
you ever had but so I go for the chicken
magnificent best chicken cutlets I've
had in a very very long time right now
good ranchers is throwing in a treat for
our listeners 30 bucks off your order
with code nolles head on over right now
to good ranchers.com use code nolles get
30 bucks off with free express shipping
code nolles kwes for 30 bucks off your
box at goodranchers.com goodranchers
American Meat delivered a judge a
Democrat judge in Colorado has just
greenlid a campaign to keep Trump off
the ballot in
Colorado uh this Judge Sarah Wallace was
appointed by the Democrat Governor Jared
paus and uh she has denied a motion by
Trump in the Colorado GOP to throw out a
lawsuit seeking to block Trump from
appearing on the ballot in Colorado and
why are they going to block Trump from
appearing on the ballot because he's an
evil rapist
insurrectionist Ukraine colluding Russia
colluding mean old orange man who we
really hate and an invisible Inc in the
Constitution it says that mean orange
men can't be on the ballot I think I
think that's pretty much the substance
of the lawsuit and this Colorado judge
says Okay can go
ahead or that's the substance of the
campaign rather and the judge says yeah
the camp can go ahead
sure okay the last time we had a
situation like this I will remind you
was 1860 people sometimes say that in
1860 Abraham Lincoln didn't appear on
the ballot in the southern states which
is not quite true because elections were
conducted differently than they are
today you didn't have a formal ballot on
a computer screen or even just printed
out it was the parties would produce the
ballots and the GOP didn't even invest
in the South because they were never
going to win and GOP was a new party
with not a lot of resources but the
effect of it was basically that Abraham
Lincoln was not a candidate that one
could even really possibly vote for in a
lot of the
country and then when he got elected
president that was a cause of the Civil
War because half the country felt that
it it didn't have any representation it
didn't really have any say whatsoever
it's this is not an identical situation
but it's pretty close if the Liberals
succeed at kicking Donald Trump off the
ballot in
2024 it's going to tell us two things
one it's going to tell us that Trump is
obviously electable one of the silliest
lines I hear is that Donald Trump can't
win the general election he can't win a
general election which I know is false
because he won at least one general
election he did a lot of people who said
the same thing in 2016 Donald Trump can
never win a general election they were
quite surprised when he won the general
election in 2016 but then they use the
uh dubious election of 2020 to say well
see now he actually he can't win all he
could not saying he will I'm just saying
he could so it's going to it the fact
that the Dems want to keep him off the
ballot shows you they don't think it's
going to be a slam dunk to defeat him at
The Ballot Box even with the vote
harvesting even with the dropboxes even
with all of their nonsense and all of
their shenanigans that open the
elections to fraud they still are not
convinced they can beat him at The
Ballot Box so they want to they want to
prevent voters from even having the
choice at The Ballot Box that's the
first thing it's going to tell you the
second thing it tells you
is we are dangerously close to not
having much of anything in common as a
country we are dangerously close to the
conditions that we were at in 18 and I'm
not one of these catastrophists who says
that we're always going to be on the
brink of Civil War and we're all going
to I'm certainly not encouraging Civil
War by any means but it could happen
just like people sometimes say do you
think we're living in the end times my
answer is I don't think we are but
someone's going to be living in the end
times I guess we could be that's kind of
how I feel about Civil War I'm not
saying that we're headed for civil war
but we could be civil wars happen and
the Liberals would appear to be
cultivating the conditions to make it
much more likely boy what a great clip
that was now hey hey hey hey ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael N show see
you next time